emmanuel macron bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir en direct dans ce
journal
vous êtes en campagne électorale et vous
avez fait le choix de venir aujourd'hui
dans un territoire souffrent de désert
médical
est-ce que vous avez des solutions pour
que tout le monde puisse être soigné en
milieu rural bonsoir et bonne année à
toutes et tous je suis très heureux en
effet d'être à nevers ce soir et d'avoir
passé l'après midi avec votre mère dans
votre hôpital de pierre bérégovoy
vous venez d'en parler tout et il n'y a
pas de réponse magique par contre il y a
une politique volontariste à mener et
c'est celle que je détaillerai ce soir
la première c'est évidemment d'aller
plus loin sur les maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires c'est-à-dire de
doubler l'effort dans les prochaines
années
c'est ce à quoi je m'engage qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement ça veut
dire développer beaucoup plus
massivement ces maisons de santé dans
lesquels on permet à des médecins
généralistes travaillent avec des
kinésithérapeutes avec d'autres
professionnels de santé parce que les
jeunes et moins jeunes aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ne veulent pas travailler
seuls ne veulent pas travailler comme
avant et leur souhait c'est
véritablement d'être ancré dans le
territoire de travailler avec d'autres
professionnels
c'est la priorité parce que c'est ce qui
permet de répondre au fait
qu'aujourd'hui un tiers de nos
départements n'ont pas de continuité des
soins d'une part et que d'autre part
tout le monde va sinon à l'hôpital au
service des urgences la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin sur les groupements ou hospitaliers
de territoire l'hôpital pierre bérégovoy
est engagée dans ce travail nous l'avons
vu cet après midi on doit aller plus
loin
décloisonner l'hôpital public avec les
structures privées et permettre aider
les territoires à avoir une vraie
politique d'attractivité c'est ce que
fait justement nevers pour attirer les
talents les spécialistes les médecins
sur ses sites dans quelques jours
emmanuel macron comment cela la primaire
de la gauche à laquelle vous avez décidé
de ne pas participer
est-ce que d'après vous cet
éparpillement des candidatures ne
condamne pas la gauche pour cette
présidentielle
j'ai décidé pour ma part depuis que je
me suis engagé en effet dans cette
campagne de le faire pour répondre aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens pour
apporter des réponses au concret et pour
porter cette offre progressiste à
laquelle je crois
depuis deux ans que des sondages sont
faits il n'y a aucun candidat de la
gauche socialiste qui arrive au second
tour aucun ça n'est pas ma candidature
qui en est la cause
ni quelques autres éléments que ce soit
c'est simplement une conséquence
factuelle que je constate comme vous
donc le problème est de leur côté pas du
mien ce que je trouve stats c'est que
depuis plusieurs mois nous avons une
dynamique qui est positif parce que la
démarche qui est la nôtre et que je
porte c'est précisément de rassembler
les progressistes de gauche de droite du
centre de la société civile toutes
celles et ceux qui se retrouvent dans
des valeurs que j'ai plusieurs fois
rappelé dans un projet que je suis en
train de détailler et qui veulent
transformer le pays pour à la fois
réussir libérer les énergies et en même
temps donner une place à chacun un
projet à la fois efficace et juste
je crois à ce regroupement je crois à ce
rassemblement des énergies et donc je ne
vais pas en effet perdre de temps dans
des chicaya parce que ce qui va se jouer
dans les prochaines semaines ce sont des
débats entre des gens qui ont déjà
divorcé puisqu'ils ont divorcé
durant les mois ou les années passées le
temps passe vite une dernière question
vous êtes en bourgogne c'est la région
d'arnaud montebourg qui présentera ses
voeux demain à blanzy vous avez tous les
deux a été ministre de l'économie
françois hollande
qu'est-ce qui en quoi provisions sont
elles différentes
écoutez y aurait beaucoup à dire là
dessus j'ai beaucoup d'amitié à titre
personnel pour arnaud montebourg c'est
aussi la région de mon ami françois
patriat qui l'a dirigé pendant plusieurs
années avec beaucoup de talent et que je
veux saluer nous n'avons pas la même
vision des choses je je crois dans la
liberté d'entreprendre
je crois dans une économie française
forte ouverte dans l'europe et dans le
monde
je crois en même temps dans des
protections individuelles repenser au
21ème siècle je crois dans une france
qui arrive à se transformer à la fois
par l'investissement et la
transformation de son de son modèle
économique de son droit du travail en
protégeant chacune et chacun
arnaud montebourg a une vision plus
colbertiste comme il le revendique
lui-même de l'économie je pense qu'elle
ne correspond pas au siècle qui s'ouvre
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir beaucoup de
respect d'amitié pour lui
merci emmanuel macron d'avoir répondu à
nos questions en direct de nevers à
dijon